bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dont le 7-8
sport numéro 32 c'est parti pour 26
minutes de reportage d'image de match et
d'interviews sur la cus portes du
département il intégré il ya quelques
semaines le top 30 mondial de tennis
fauteuil joueurs depuis seulement six
ans johan guillou connaît une
progression fulgurante et vise les jeux
olympiques de rio 2016 il s'appelle lui
pascal boulanger y les piliers du
plaisir rugby club avec un mètre 87 % 25
kg il possède un gabarit hors norme qui
fait déjà beaucoup de dégâts en fédérale
3 et enfin dans ce set 8 sport retour
sur le derby entre le promu sartrouville
et montigny lors de la 4e journée de
régionale une de volleyball des
retrouvailles aux allures de revanche
après la demi-finale de coupe des
yvelines de juin prochain évidemment en
fin d'émission tous les résultats du
week-end mais tout d'abord place à notre
page spéciale tennis fauteuil
donc je le disais un johan guillou vous
avez intégré il ya quelques semaines le
top 30 mondial ou on vous avez rencontré
au printemps vous étiez 35e 36e joueur
mondial bonsoir à vous un tout d'abord
merci de passer sur le 7-8 sport sur
cette saison complète au haut niveau est
ce que vous êtes satisfait de cette
progression est de cette intégration du
top 30 et bien évidemment je suis
satisfait puisque l'année dernière j'ai
terminé mon année 2012 45e joueur
mondial et cette année 2013 je m'étais
donné comme objectif donc d'intégrer le
top 30 donc c'est le top 30 c'est
vraiment d'intégrer le on va dire de
jouer le gradin de jouer que les
meilleurs joueurs du monde et objective
validé puisque depuis à peu près
maintenant quelques semaines j'ai je
suis maintenant la 21e 29e place
mondiale donc au classement
international il ya une belle
progression je le disais dans les titres
1 vous jouez au tennis depuis très peu
qu'est ce qu'est le domaine il faut
encore améliorer pour que vous intégrez
peut-être dans un ou deux ans une ou
deux saisons le top-15 le top 10 mondial
mais en fait j'ai encore beaucoup de
travail techniquement voilà j'ai comme
vous le dites j'ai commencé le tennis il
ya six 6 ans et en un an j'ai énormément
progressé après c'est sur des petits
détails un ça va être de la puissance
avait travaillé ma préparation physique
mentale et encore améliorer ma ma
gestuelle ma mon tennis comme tous les
tous les coups du tennis tout simplement
je vois que cette saison vous avez fait
de bons résultats dans les tournois itf
1 c'est un peu la deuxième le deuxième
circuit un petit peu des tournois
principaux à travers le monde mais pas
de grand chelem encore où il ya une
vraie performance il ya un problème de
déclic un cap à passer sur ses tournois
du grand chelem à roland garros et us
open bah tout simplement que les grands
chelems en fait c'est les huit meilleurs
joueurs mondiaux qui seront invités en
fait donc pour l'instant j'en suis un
petit peu loin mais j'espère que ça
arrivera un jour moi même de jouer c'est
roman la cua ont trouvé ça dommage que
ça reste un petit peu trop fermé au
final c'est c'est que ces grands chefs
oui mais c'est qu'en fait huit joueurs
ça fait quand même peu et apparemment
j'ai entendu dire que ça passerait
peut-être à ses joueurs l'année
prochaine donc ce serait plutôt
intéressant pour moi si je me donne
comme objectif d'ici deux ans de rentrer
dans le top 15 sur cette saison 2013 il
ya forcément un souvenir déjà qui marque
avec une première saison au niveau non
si on l'a joint par équipes et plusieurs
individuellement donc j'en ai tout
d'abord notre titre de champion de
france 2e série avec mon coéquipier
régis harel voilà où en fait mon moi
c'était presque un devoir de remporter
ses sept médailles d'or et c'est aussi
je peux remercier également à travers ce
titre voilà tout un club toute une
section tous mes coaches qui ont
travaillé avec nous tout au long des
entraînements et
voilà je le dédie aussi ce titre toutes
ces personnes là parce que là vous
l'avez gagné en double l'hiver dernier
vous aviez aussi remporté le titre en
simple mais en 2e série il manque plus
que le titre en première série ben voilà
les prochains championnats de france on
se dérouler début décembre comme vous le
dites j'ai déjà mon titre de champion de
france 2e série que j'ai acquis en
décembre 2012 et donc là mon objectif
c'est au moins de
deux mois la devise est la troisième
voire la quatrième place pour les
prochains championnats de france 1re
série puisque du coup je vais jouer que
les 8 meilleurs joueurs nationaux n'ont
que c'est encore une étape de plus quoi
donc une étape de plus qui pourrait être
difficile sur le papier parce qu'on sait
que le tennis handisport français est
bien fourni un bien garni je pense bien
sûr à stéphane b frédéric cattaneo
monsieur paper aussi vous il ya quatre
joueurs mais quelle jeremias qui sont
dans le top 10 mondial déjà donc la
décrocher le titre national ça va être
compliqué oui non mais c'est sûr que ça
va être compliqué je dis pas que je vais
le décrocher mais en tout cas j'ai envie
de me faire plaisir sur ces championnats
j'ai vraiment envie de jouer mon tennis
d'accrocher ces jours là et comme je
vous dis voilà l'échéance
voilà l'échéance on va dire sur le plus
long terme c'est pourquoi pas les jeux
et sames deux ans et demi trois ans pour
jouer jouer et faire des matchs contre
ses joueurs du top 15 top 10 mondial
j'allais venir les jeux olympiques de
rio 2016 on sait que c'est un mot doux
rêve
quel domaine comment vous allez faire
pour décrocher sept 7 sélections
olympiques
déjà je vais continuer à travailler
parce que je pense que
il va falloir que je continue à
m'entraîner régulièrement voire même
multiplié les entraînements une fois que
je me dégage du temps aussi pour bien
préparer physiquement mentalement
et puis continuer à faire le circuit
international
gagner des tournois maintenant est
comment ces ajustements père fait comme
on dit faire des pères sur des joueurs
de ce top 20 mondial
voilà je pense qu'il n'y a pas deux il
ya c'est sale ça va être ça je pense les
projets pour créer les clés attraper le
haut niveau juste avant que vous nous
quittiez johan sûr c'est sur cette
édition de cette fuite sport je vous
propose d'inaugurer la nouvelle
chronique un petit peu de l'émission ça
s'appelle le quiz le plus tôt ou plutôt
il va falloir répondre très très vite je
vais vous poser des questions assez
simple mais il n'y a pas de piège
d'accord on essaye de répondre le plus
rapidement possible alors tout d'abord
vous êtes plutôt nadal ou federer nadal
vous êtes plutôt roland garros wimbledon
roland-garros plutôt service volée ou
fond de court fond de court plutôt
numéro un mondial ou médaille aux jeux
olympiques de rio 2016 médailles aux
jeux de 2016 plutôt de tsonga ou gasquet
chez les valides tsonga est enfin plus
tôt serena williams ou maria sharapova
maria sharapova
on remercie beaucoup d'encre car donc on
aura compris maria sharapova à vos
faveurs en fait c'est un costaud merci
yohann d'être passés sur le 7-8 sport et
donc rendez vous pour les champions de
france 1re série début décembre merci à
ou
pour le compte de la 4e journée de
régionale une de voler cette fois-ci
montigny recevait le promu sartrouville
j'en parlais tout à l'heure après avoir
été éliminé en demi finale de coupe des
yvelines la saison dernière les joueurs
d'abdellatif michery pardon avait à
coeur de s'imposer dans ce derby
résultat avec jonathan vilma il y avait
comme un air de revanche au complexe
jean maréchal après leur élimination en
demi finale de coupe des yvelines
montigny retrouver le promu sartrouville
afin de prouver sa suprématie en
championnat qui dit derby dit fin des
mauvaises habitudes lésigny montanes ne
loupe pas l'occasion de prendre les
devants dans la première manche une
précision retrouver aux combinaisons
leur permet d'empocher le premier set 25
21 on commence timidement montini a été
agressive tout de suite je pense qu'ils
avaient une envie de revanche par
rapport à ce qui s'est passé un peu
dernière en coupe des yvelines
où on avait pris le dessus justement à
l'envi
voilà on n'est pas du tout dans l'est
dans l'agressivité on est on est trop
gentil face à une équipe qui avait
vraiment envie de nous battre à quelque
chose aujourd'hui bis repetita dans le
second set les joueurs d'abdellatif
micheli confirment leur emprise sur le
match 25 18 mai dans la 3e manche les
blancs baisse de rythme et sartrouville
s'engouffre dans la brèche 25 14 pour
les visiteurs lésigny monte à 1 re met
alors lors ce match à l'endroit et sa
rage dans le quatrième acte qu'il
remporte 25 22 le service qui était un
point faible des saint quentinois les
dernières semaines a enfin été efficace
on a pris des risques au service ils ont
un jeu offensif très très très puissant
on a pris beaucoup de risques ou
services beaucoup de services toxiques
aussi donc on va essayer de nous très
neutre à neutraliser au maximum leur jeu
offensif ça a payé au premier ou
deuxième set on a des c impliquons
services de troisième set donc ils sont
un peu rattrapé mais quand vous y ait
encore une fois c'est le mental que nous
a permis de rester de nom il rien lâcher
parce qu'on avait une revanche je suis
très content c'est une revanche c'est
une équipe qui nous avait
même humilié
à la demi finale les yvelines donc on
avait une petite revanche envers cette
équipe là et leur montrer que on était
complètement passé à côté et la série
quand on est pour la manière
et pour le résultat c'est la deuxième
victoire consécutive des idées mon teint
cette saison il remonte à la 4e place et
ne sont plus qu'à deux points de
sartrouville troisième
après le derby en volleyball place au
débriefing de la deuxième saison en
élite du triathlon club de saint quentin
en yvelines évidemment pour en parler
jean françois rime unis est passé sur le
7-8 sport bonsoir à vous
tout d'abord première question deuxième
saison en élite cette fois-ci vous
intégrer le top 5 après avoir fait après
avoir finir 8e 1 la saison dernière
j'imagine que la satisfaction est énorme
ouais bien sûr intégrer le top 5 que
c'est un objectif qu'on s'était fixés
sur trois ans on l'a atteint au bout de
la deuxième année donc on est
relativement satisfait derrière 3 3
grosses écuries bon qui sera difficile
d'aller les chercher mais on ne perd pas
espoir je pense que les les athlètes ont
fait une bonne saison ils sont bien
revenus dans le dans le rythme et ils
ont oublié un petit peu les blessures de
début de saison qui nous donne un petit
peu handicapé donc oui pour l'année
prochaine y en ai plein de pleins
d'espoir pour cette nouvelle saison 2014
pour rappel les trois premières
cylindrée 1 dans ce championnat de
france élite 1 c'est poissy et une vidéo
à sartrouville aussi un 10 décidément le
triathlon est très présent dans les
idées non le sait et puis du côté de la
vendée 1 sa mère qui était champion de
france il ya quelques semaines même
noyau que quasiment inchangé le noyau de
vaud triathlète entre les deux saisons
ça montre qu'il ya aussi une prise de
confiance
devaux triathlète on a surtout oublié
les blessures quand vous avez des
joueurs du top qui sont blessés c'est
très très compliqué d'aligner les
résultats on a une petite en une petite
équipe on va dire une petite équipe en
nombre qu'en qualité mais en nombre une
petite équipe dès qu'on a un blessé on a
tout de suite un trou un trou à la
combler c'est cool c'est compliqué parce
que les résultats se font
sur les trois meilleurs donc c'est
vraiment compliqué d'avoir des bons
résultats donc qu' on va essayer pendant
l'an prochain d'étoffer un peu cet
officier tic cette équipe pour qu'on ait
un petit peu moins de problèmes sur le
championnat avec les blessures voyez
vous le disiez les blessures c'est ça
notamment concernés fred belaubre oui
c'est un lieu aussi un arbre de l'équipe
et qui a été champion d'europe on ne le
présente plus trois fois champion
d'europe et là qui étaient présents et
bien présent sur cette saison ça
peut-être aussi aider les jeunes comme
thomas andré à aymeric pétel à se
surpasser au 8 août a fait avec quentin
fred et là il s'est un peu c'est un peu
la mobylette comme on dit un dès que le
joueur majeur est en forme ça ça tire
tout le monde vers le haut un et là ça a
été le cas cette année il est bienvenu
l'a fait vraiment une saison une fin de
saison tonitruante il a fait vraiment
des très bons résultats surtout en
course à pied qui était vraiment si on
dit cap de l'an dernier bon c'est
extrêmement satisfaisant pour le team hm
il fait le meilleur temps d'ailleurs au
grand prix de nice ainsi fanny je fais
mes meilleurs temps en course à pied
c'est énorme avec un chien et dix
champions du monde qui était là le
champion du monde u23 qui étaient là non
non non c'est une très belle performance
l'équipe élite a très bien fonctionné
cette année on espère peut-être un
podium l'année prochaine sait-on jamais
mais il ya un jeune aussi du côté du
triathlon club de saint quentin en
yvelines qui fonctionne bien c'est alan
bras chez canon aux quelque chose
d'incroyable d'historique même même
cette saison c'est qui est tout
simplement triple champion de france
dans sa catégorie en fonction des
épreuves c'est tout simplement un
phénomène non c'est c'est incroyable
qu'il a réalisé cette année et
positivement incroyable il a les trois
types dans les trois disciplines
aquathlon duathlon triathlon il est
champion de france par équipe avec la
ligue ile de france et depuis deux jours
il est champion du monde scolaire à
porto rico c'est une saison
extraordinaire
vous vous projetez déjà de l'intégrer
peut-être la saison prochaine tout
doucement dans ce groupe élite où il ya
encore un peu trop jeune non non l'an
prochain il a il a toutes les chances
d'intégrer les slot qu'on a une estrade
supplémentaire qu'on a dans cette équipe
élite qui permettent justement
d'acquérir les jeunes sur des
championnats qui sont d'un niveau très
élevé puisque c'est le niveau mondial
donc c'est encore un peu compliqué pour
eux mais je pense que c'est une très
belle une très belle marche je pense
qu'il a largement le potentiel pour
intégrer ces slot et et courir le
championnat d1 oui c'est sûr dernière
question jean-françois l'objectif la
saison prochaine claire est ce qu'on
peut aller aller chercher un podium du
côté de saint quentin en yvelines sur ce
championnat de france élite ou savait
trop dur avec poissy sartrouville et et
sables vendée ce sera très compliqué ce
sera très compliqué mais si ça veut
rigoler comme on dit un si on est
passionné par nier par les blessures et
si on a les joueurs qui sont au top
rien n'est impossible donc si rien est
impossible on espère en tout cas du coup
peut-être un podium alors dans un an ici
même avec un nouveau débriefer puis
espérons pour le triage ouais c'est cool
tous les malheurs du choix est tout
aussi sûr merci beaucoup jean françois
est passé sur le site du sport une
nouvelle fois puis à bientôt infligée au
pays pour la nouvelle saison avec un
mètre 87 et 125 kg pascal boulanger
possède un gabarit hors norme à 19 ans
le pilier plaisir hu a fait des débuts
fracassants pour sa première saison en
fédérale 3 de rugby après être prêtre
être passé par nom par le centre de
formation de bourgoin jallieu portrait
l'histoire entre pascal boulanger et le
rugby cherche toujours le retour aux
sources comme la relation vitale entre
un talonneur et son pilier en mêlée le
pack le saint quentinois s'y frotte pour
la première fois à l'âge de 9 ans à
montigny au poste de deuxième ligne
repéré par carcassonne chez les juniors
il tente sa chance dans la cathédrale
des avants le centre de formation de
bourgoin jallieu mais loin de ses
attaches le colosse ne trouve pas ses
repères et revient au bercail après
quatre petits mois je vais assume
complètement
j'ai progressé en étant là bas et j'ai
vécu une aventure que j'avais à vivre
voilà maintenant je suis content de
l'avoir fait je regrette pas mais je
suis content d'être rentré aussi il
aurait pu s'amuser en championnat de
france mais le pilier saint quentinois
de 19 ans tenait d'abord à remercier son
club formateur mancini c'est le club qui
m'a formé et que je leur devais au moins
un minimum une saison l'équipe senior
pour les remercier tout simplement et
pour essayer de faire quelque chose vu
qu'on était en 1ère série nous pour
essayer de monter en promotion d'honneur
ça c'est pas fait malheureusement
j'aurais aimé quitter le club en montant
philibert avait déjà repéré ses qualités
physiques chez les jeunes vu le
potentiel du gamin 1 m 87 % 25 kg sur la
balance le staff plaisir roy va devoir
faire des pieds et des mains pour
conserver son pilier grosse abnégation
c'est quelqu'un qu'on voit pas beaucoup
qui parle pas beaucoup mais qui fait le
travail et puis après physiquement c'est
une certaine si tu me coin il avance sur
tous les impacts heures en défense ils
trains etr à rien et quand il a même sa
marque dans un maul dans un ruck pour un
confort rock ça ça se voit bon joueur de
ballon passe om longer la touche et
inscrire comme lors de la dernière
journée 2 essais en bout de ligne il
fait d'ailleurs partie des meilleurs
marqueurs du prc ou très bonne
intégration il assimile très très vite
les combinaisons on va ce quelqu'un qui
est très très bien aussi bien sur le
terrain que humainement parlant en
dehors du terrain et franchement c'est
que du plaisir d'évoluer aux côtés de
joueurs comme ça surtout pour renforcer
l'équipe et atteindre l'objectif qu'on
s'est fixé cette année car la montée en
fédérale 2 pascal boulanger y pense à
chaque match le coût serait parfait pour
sa première saison sous les couleurs du
prc le succès là où tout a commencé
car paso n'est jamais aussi bon que
lorsqu'il revient aux sources
et on passe tout de suite aux résultats
du week-end
place au handball et petit événement ce
week-end montigné a empoché sa première
victoire de la saison en championnat de
nationale 2 championnats de france
lésigny montaigne se déplaçait à bar le
duc en lorraine et elles se sont imposés
26 23 après avoir maîtrisé leur avance
en seconde période avec ce premier
succès les joueuses de stéphane paysans
remonte à la 7e place de leur poule
football pas de journée de division
d'honneur ce week-end ou de promotion
d'honneur pour cause de coupe de france
une compétition où il n'y a plus aucun
club saint quentinois encore en lice
mais le championnat d'excellence vous le
voyez ne faisait pas de pause pour le
compte de la 5e journée versailles
deuxième s'est imposé à domicile face à
montigny 2 1 12e et dernier de son côté
plaisir 9e s'est lourdement incliné face
au 6e chatou 4 buts à 1 en football
féminin en division 2 ans eut évidemment
montigny et toujours pas de victoire
cette saison pour les aînés monteyne les
joueuses de jean dany grossesse sont
inclinés à amiens cette fois ci 3 à 0
sur un triplé de mélanie brito au
classement évidemment les inhumant ten
reste lanterne rouge de leur groupe de
division 2 avec seulement 5 petits
points en cinq journées les
saint-quentinoises n'ont pas marqué ou
quasiment pas de reprise seulement
depuis le début de la saison les jours
de jordanie grossesse sur le banc
semblent comptés en basket week-end
difficile pour les clubs saint
quentinois aucune victoire en fin de
compte quatrième journée de national une
féminine l'entente le chesnay versailles
est passé tout près de la victoire at
war et pourtant les joueuses de stéphane
drolet se sont inclinés 2 3 petits
points 64 à 61 elle reste 4e au
classement chez les hommes trappe s'est
incliné à malakoff 63 49 et de son côté
le fcv n'a rien pu faire face au
ministère des finances défaite 84 à 55
courses à pied maintenant en ce week end
la base de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines accueillait la cinquième
édition de l'ekiden marathon par équipe
1 je vous le rappelle sur une boucle de
2,5 km les participants se relayaient à
leur gré pour parcourir les 42 km 195
65 équipes ont pris le départ dimanche
matin à 9 heures une épreuve remportée
par une 2d une des deux équipes chèque
est venu pour la compétition
spécialement en 2h24 à chacun sa
tactique pour rallier l'arrivée dans le
meilleur temps possible évidemment
l'ekiden c'est aussi l'occasion de
trouver les régler pour les courses à
venir pour la saison prochaine
on doit écouter un décor c'est pas de
gagner le challenge quoi que ce soit
c'est entre nous c'est l'émulation s'est
essayé de me battre
entre nous au plus haut en début de
saison on connaît pas surtout les
nouveaux on les connaît pas donc ça
permet de savoir un petit peu ce qu'ils
valent sur des distances qui sont pas
trop longue et puis en fonction de ça on
va pouvoir adapter leur entraînement
tout pour pouvoir les amener à faire
mieux la prochaine fois
roller hockey eux aussi vont devoir
faire mieux la prochaine fois les chocs
d'elancourt troisième journée de
nationale 2 ils recevaient rouen et ils
se sont ils sont passés tout près en
fait de leur première victoire de la
saison grâce à une superbe entame de
match les visiteurs mènent rapidement 3
0 en première période les joueurs de
benjamin ferran réduiront l'écart en fin
de en fin de rencontre pour finalement
perdre cette rencontre 5 4 les chocs
sont toujours derniers de leur poule
volley ball pour finir une d1 derniers
résultats 4e journée de régionale une on
en parlait avec montigny tout à l'heure
et là ces plaisirs qui s'est une
nouvelle fois imposé à domicile 3 sets à
1 face à orsay chevry 25 20 25 14 et 25
18 trois athlètes du club de guyancourt
orientation une autre info étaient
sélectionnés pour la coupe d'europe
jeunes juniors il ya une semaine et la
jeune lauriane beau visage des revenus
de saint-etienne avec une troisième
place en relais féminin vous la voyez
apparaître sur la droite de l'écran
après avoir échoué au pied du podium sur
le sprinter de son côté le jeune quentin
roturier s'est classé 10e dans la
catégorie des moins de 18 ans
sport de combat maintenant ce mercredi
soir petites annonces telit du tech
point n 2 mondiale sera de passage au
complexe pierre de coubertin
montigny-le-bretonneux une trentaine de
jeunes combattants sud coréen est
originaire de mouches ou âgés de 8 à 18
ans effectuera une démonstration nous
jouer la ville du futur siège de la
fédération internationale de taekwondo
histoire de vous faire un petit peu
saliver eric naudin précédé président du
tk des 78 nous parlent de leur potentiel
ils ont un niveau technique que peut
même d'adultes obtiennent un chez nous
en france ils sont vraiment
extraordinaires ils vont passer par
toutes les étapes que ce soit de la
casse de la casse acrobatique bien
évidemment du combat de la chorégraphie
type poomsé enfin ils vont vraiment où
on présentait son super dynamique
enfin la java du week-end un pour
clôturer ce 7,8 sport une première date
tennis de table premier match à domicile
des féminines de l'entente voisin
saint-arnoult les joueuses de geoffrey
nisand accueilleront seclin ce samedi 19
octobre à 17 heures au gymnase des
pyramides en rugby championnat d'honneur
le sky rugby défiera cergy-pontoise coup
d'envoi à 15 heures au stade du bout des
clauses ce dimanche et enfin un petit
événement un petit parti un petit peu
particulier ça dit il s'agit du man
event tournoi de poker qui se déroule
tout le week-end gymnase chantal mauduit
à magny les hameaux 200 joueurs seront
présents début des parties à 9h30 samedi
matin c'est la fin de ce set 8 faut
remercier encore une fois de l'avoir
suivi n'hésitez pas à nous donner tous
les résultats de vos clubs via les
réseaux sociaux et twitter avec le
hashtag le 7-8 sport tout attaché à
lundi prochain bonne soirée